The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at NCAA
JULIAN BEINART: OK,
we need to talk.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sorry.
JULIAN BEINART: No,
no, don't be sorry.
I'm sorry I have to talk.
[LAUGHTER]
We've been going for 20--
I think this is the 21st class.
We have 26 altogether.
I'm going to combine
two classes today
simply, because I want to leave
some more time at the end.
We run out of time
at the end, and I'm
going to try to do this
heroic task of combining
two classes into one.
OK, have you got this handout?
It deals with two topics.
First of all, let me
set the framework.
I argued that modernism was
an existential preoccupation
with the present, given that
the present was sufficiently
rich and exploratory and
creative, and absolutely devoid
of the past.
He didn't speculate
much about the future,
arguing that if you take care
of your existence at the moment,
particularly if you are on
the verge of a new world,
prediction was not necessary.
Curiously enough, the
past was not necessarily
intellectually either.
This is just not because
of the absence of culture.
This is largely a
European movement
to which people have been
thinking and philosophizing
about architecture and urbanism
for thousands of years.
So the hermetic phenomenon of
modernism led me to explore,
in last week's lecture,
in the postmodern version
of trying to use
devices such as geometry
to enhance the future
change, accepting
that the future implies change.
It's difficult to precisely
be clear about to the extent
that stochastic methods
enable one to know something
about the future.
Together with that
was a preoccupation
with the immensely larger
notion of the present,
much more interested
in the complexity
of the understanding
of the present
than modernism thought of.
For Corbusier, the
relegation of the plane
of buildings in the
city to greenspace
didn't ask a question about
the institutional framework
for creating or
maintaining such a system.
There were no questions
about what security
would be like in a
green plane of a city
with no local monitoring.
Modernism was [? pre-crime, ?]
pre the maleability of social
institutions to allow people
to take part in decisions
in a democracy.
It was apolitical, so Corbusier
could shift his correct plan
from corporate capitalism
to colonial Algiers
to syndicalist Moscow, making
plans for each of these,
given the geometric
formations would be absolute.
What I want to try to do
today to deal with the past.
If we are now blessed with axes
both forward and backwards,
we have a much richer and
even more difficult to
deal with urban existence.
And we try to make the world
of the past more complex.
It divides itself into
two systems of knowledge--
history and memory.
I'll spend a bit
of time with each,
and try to give you some
accounting of the difference
between history and memory, and
spend a lot more time on memory
than on history.
The first page of
the handout deals
with the list of 10 different
attitudes and practices
regarding the past.
You can add number 11,
which I haven't, which
I've since added, which deals
with remembering at a distance.
This phenomenon of
remembering at a distance
has become much more
available to us.
It was available to
the Jews in 70 AD when
they left the last temple
and went into the diaspora,
but remembered Jerusalem in
their prayers every Passover,
even today, returning
to Jerusalem
being part of the mantra.
Remembering at a
distance is also
possible in the interpretation
of Christianity, which I gave,
when Jesus in the forequarter
of the second Jewish temple
says the temple will be
destroyed in a number of years.
He says to his
disciples, remember
that my body will be your
temple, referring in some ways
to the canonical version
of Christianity which
interprets Christ's body in the
mass through blood and bread.
Still today, it's remembering
at a distance [INAUDIBLE]..
So given that we
have an increase
in the diasporas of the
world through migration,
we just had an incident
this month in Boston,
which deals with the
phenomenologically difficult
notion of interpreting
allegiance
through after migration.
This is a contemporary
problem, and it
makes urbanism very
much more difficult,
given conventional
notions of allegiance
to city, to state, to nation.
I had a thesis two years
ago, done by a Korean woman
from Los Angeles, who analyzed
the-- do you know the thesis.
AUDIENCE: You told me about it.
JULIAN BEINART: Oh, did I?
I'm sorry.
We analyzed the status
of immigrant groups
in Los Angeles, where I think
one third of the population
are non-American, or in the
process of becoming American.
For them, there
was no city center
to give allegiance to as in
the traditional spatial form
of the city.
So she took upon herself
to utilize the emerging
underground public
transportation
system as a dispersed
form of identity
for a migrated population, who
are generally poorer, anyway.
I don't want to get on to that.
Let me tell you the sequence
of what we're going to do.
And we go briefly
through this list,
give you some
indications of examples,
and then going to
go to number 6--
no, number 8 and 9
to analyze briefly
the ideas of two urban
theorists of recent time, Aldo
Rossi, the Italian who won
the Prtizker Prize stupidly.
He wasn't stupid, but the
Pritzker committee was stupid.
He's a man who wrote a very
good book called Architecture
of the City as a theorist
who taught it in Switzerland,
but his buildings are
sacrilegiously bad
and very few.
And seeing the
Pritzker prizes still
reward people not for theory,
but for practice, it's a shame.
This shows how misguided
architectural criticism is.
And the other is
Leon Krier, whom
I've chosen as an arch
example of classicism
as a method of dealing
with the present
through the lens of the past.
For the rest, I will
choose examples and slide
which indicate examples
from all of this list.
Let me just go through
the list very briefly.
You can reshape as before.
The ghetto in Warsaw
was built much
like the version
of the ghetto which
the Jews revolted in at the
end of the '39, '45 war.
So for parts of Bologna--
you can build anew.
One of the best examples
is the rebuilding
of the center of
Rotterdam, and I there's
an illustration of
both in the text.
Number 3, make an open
system to allow memory
to be achieved over time.
This is the example of the
Free University in Berlin.
We don't do anything
to mark the past.
We leave it open to
the community who
lives there to create their own
monuments, their own memories,
their own museums, their own
patterns, their own geometries.
If of the past, good enough.
If not of the past,
but existentially only
of the present, good enough.
There is a early
electronic website.
[INAUDIBLE] was in my class,
in an advanced version
of this class, when
he was a student here
doing his doctorate.
He unearthed an
electronic program
which people could join.
There was a site somewhere,
nowhere, electronically,
and people could occupy
space systematically
in this virtual space.
After a time, the
historical society
grew up in this virtual space.
I imagine the need to program
your life in sequence.
Freud said something-- well,
I'll quote Freud in a minute.
Let's rather stick
to my program.
So easy to jump
from one to another.
And before, leave
all your fragments,
but add a new program.
This plays on the duality
of meaning between a remnant
of the past and the present.
Church Court is a good example.
Church Court has dual
meaning, or at least
pertains to a dual meaning.
You know what Church Court is.
This is just the building
just across the bridge
on Beacon Street.
The fragments of the
church are maintained,
and a new apartment
building is added to it.
Freud said something
extraordinary.
I can't find the quotation here.
But Freud says that it is
impossible to represent
the same content pictorially
in the same image.
If you want to share how
Rome has grown over time,
you have to
juxtapose situations.
You cannot spatially have a
unique meaning which has both
ingredients in it
according to Freud.
Therefore, it says, to
represent mental processes
through pictorially
image is a waste of time,
for it is implying that
in our mental mechanism
we are able to
simultaneously think
of our mother and our
girlfriend simultaneously.
But we cannot depict spatial
contexts simultaneously.
Now, juxtaposing the two
formal elements of Church Court
is a method.
A Freudian-- not Freudian,
it's a pretty pedantic method
of getting meaning from
the past and associating
with meaning with the present.
There was a church here.
That is a memory function.
There is now a building now.
This is modern.
There's no memory
yet attached to it.
So in the space-time continuum,
you're representing meanings
at different times.
You are also marking
urbanisticlly the fact
that on that corner,
there was a church,
and there was a
community of people
who worshipped in the
Back Bay prior to them
immigrating, and leaving
the need for the Back Bay
to produce only fewer churches.
You can play around with this
game as long as you want to.
I'll give you a
number of examples
of the obscurity of this game.
And architects at times, like
Peter Eisenman and others,
have played around.
In fact the Freudian quote
comes from Peter Eisenman's
introduction to
the Rossi's book.
Number 5, you can connect
to past urban traces,
mostly invisible.
I will show you a
couple of examples,
one of the Peter Eisenman
studio at Harvard using memory
to obscure memory traces
from the Midwestern town,
and also from the Bicocca
Pirelli Competition in Milan
and number of years ago, which
all the world's architects took
part in.
I will show you the second prize
entry by the firm from Torino
called Gabetti and
Isola, who tried
to use traces of
agrarian Roman fields
in their ecologically
advanced project.
The trouble with obscure traces
is that they're not present.
Who in the hell can recount a
past history without reference
to it?
We did a studio in Taipei
looking at the city center.
The city center was based
on an old Chinese plan.
The Japanese came along
and changed the orientation
of the original plan.
Some of our students
tried to show this fact.
But how do you show two
geometries at the same time?
You can overlay one on another,
but it's difficult to explain.
But it's not a common,
but a real option.
Number 6, create new tectonics
based on memory forms.
The explicit example of
that is the Holocaust Museum
in Washington.
Anybody been to the
Holocaust museum?
Four people.
I'll quote James Ingo Freed,
the architect who designed it,
and his references to using
forms borrowed from Auschwtiz--
Arbeit macht frei.
And we can judge the quality
of the present experience,
whose aim is to
teach us to remember
the events of the past.
We have a whole panoply of
items, which we use spatially
to remember the past--
museums, memorials,
monuments, amongst others.
I haven't got time
in this class to go
into the theory of
monuments, but we'll
talk a bit about them.
Number 7, build monuments,
memorials, museums.
Here we have a conflict.
Robert Musil, the
French philosopher,
said there is nothing as
invisible as a monument, which
means that the monument
is made psychologically
current or non-existent by time.
Which kid who goes
to Washington,
and is not told that that's
the Washington Monument,
knows that it's the
Washington Monument?
Who even knows who
Washington was?
Washington's a famous enough
person to be remembered.
But there's is a town
in Russia, a small town,
named after Engels, and
one named after Marx.
And they just they are
undistinguished and not even
on anybody's map.
It's not that Marx
is not remembered,
but the physical manifestation
of him in a monument to him
is neglected.
I'll look very briefly--
although I haven't
got the slides
to show you because of
time, of a new device
to take care of the lack
of presence of monuments.
I advised the United
States Air Force
on the selection of
a site in Washington.
The United States Air Force
wished to follow the Navy.
The Navy have-- do you
know the Navy side?
It's opposite the-- it's a
developer project in downtown,
which has a semicircular plain,
piazza, on which stands a Navy
soldier and a map of the world.
But in order to go
into the museum,
you have to go into
a developer building.
And there's a computer
program on which you
can show your grandchild
a picture of yourself
in the Navy in 1927,
or whatever it is.
Our clients, the United
States Air Force,
wished to follow the
same tradition of having
two items in a museum.
One is a symbolic fixed
item, and secondly
an updatable present.
The first design
by architect who
happened to be the same
architect as the Holocaust
museum, Jim Freed, had a plane
with the basement underneath.
And the basement had all
of the updating mechanisms.
So you could go, but above
it was a huge symbolic item.
In fact, the memorial was
never built on that site,
because the Marines argued that
we were too close to the Iwo
Jima Memorial, which is a
literal evacuation of soldiers
fighting on an
island in the Orient.
Anyway, I'm getting
carried away.
Let's stick to this program.
Number 8 and number 9--
number 8 is what I would refer
to in the work of Leon Krier.
That is the establishment
of European classicism
as a universal past
independent of time, economy,
and culture, and therefore
the DNA of the past.
And therefore, when you work
with the DNA of the past,
whether it be New Delhi or
in Richmond Terrace in London
on the river, you are
doing greater things.
And we'll examine Poundbury,
the town that Leon Krier advised
Prince Charles on.
Prince Charles is
very much involved
in the same classicism
versus modernism argument,
arguing that London's
been defaced by modernism.
And here, although I won't
go into it in detail,
we can add the phenomenon of
new urbanism to this category.
To use classical
form is a choice.
It's a stupid choice,
but it's a choice.
You can't blame people for
disliking modernism when it
appeared, and for a long time.
And so include them
in your client group
as active participants
in your design.
To use nostalgia as reminiscent
of a lost past is silly.
The new urbanism doesn't deal
with contemporary issues--
social equity, overuse of
automobile transportation,
et cetera, et cetera.
Diversity of population
in the metropolitan areas
is a diverse new
urban phenomenon.
It recreates
nostalgic pasts which
satisfies one much like candy
satisfies a child before he
grows up and nourishes himself
to believe the candy is not
good for your body.
You need to eat decent food.
Number 9, we can use
Aldo Rossi's argument
that the city has autonomous
basic forms and places which
perpetuate themselves--
the idea the locus, which
I will discuss in a minute.
Number 10, let context make
the proper associations.
This is a very appropriate form
taught in architecture schools.
Rossi argues
absolutely against it.
He says that
buildings make places,
and places don't make buildings,
and it's foolish for a building
to be made up of
adaptations of what
people have done in the past.
It's a strange kind of
notion, but there's a politics
associated with context.
For instance, the
expanding Spaniards
destroyed Cusco to a plane
and rebuilt it from scratch.
They didn't destroy the
Alhambra in post-Islam Spain.
How is it that the Crusaders
didn't destroy the Dome
of the Rock or the
Al-Asqa mosque--
simply put a flag on it?
Historians have argued that
[INAUDIBLE] be out of respect
for the quality of
the architecture.
Now, this assumes a
conquering program having
a DNA which includes respect.
AUDIENCE: It also assumes
that [INAUDIBLE] culture
[INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah, it
regards colonial cultures,
as the British [INAUDIBLE]
regarded Indian architecture as
pathetic, as childish,
as still to be achieved.
It's a little remarkable,
given the history of Islam
and the European
center that they
would regard Islamic
architecture quite
as automatically as they did.
Maybe they were worn
out in the [INAUDIBLE]
They took a hell of a long
time to get rid of Islam.
They spent all
generations of resources,
and then remembering
it at distance.
The other example of number
6, other than the Holocaust
Museum, which comes to mind is
the building you might know.
In Verona is Carlos
Scarpa's Castelvecchio, one
of the finest, if
not the finest,
example of preservation
architecture
I think in modern times
or in recent times.
Castelvecchio, which I won't
illustrate-- because I had
to choose the number of slide.
I'll try not to share
more than 30 slides--
60 slides per class.
And it's very difficult at time.
Castelvecchio was the
home of a royal family--
Scaligeri, I think they were.
In 1925, it was
made into a museum.
In 1956, Carlos Scarpa was
asked to integrate the two.
And he took the
forms of the past
and introduced them
to the new building
in a way which I think Jim Freed
did in the Holocaust Museum.
But this is difficult work,
and there are not many.
I'm sure you can think
of examples as well.
But these are the
two that come to mind
when I think of this category.
Let's go to Aldo Rossi briefly,
and then to Leon Krier briefly.
Rossi uses the past as
a tool for understanding
the present form of the city.
For Rossi, past is a continuum
of which we are still a part.
The past is perpetuated almost
fossilized in the city form,
even as that form and its
use are constantly changing.
Primary elements
of the city form
are perpetuated, through
time creating an autonomous
system of basic
absolute forms around
which the city has been,
and continues to be, built.
It's my abstraction.
Let's look at a couple
of things that he argues.
He argues that
there is a dialectic
between the city as
stones and mortar,
the actual physical artifact,
and the city of our minds--
an ideal city that
embodies experiences,
meaning, and understanding that
is autonomous of time and use.
Rossi doesn't discuss
memory very much,
but what he's talking
about are much more
the attributes of memory than
the attributes of history.
He refers in his
book to the work
of Maurice Halbwachs, the
French sociologist who
wrote a book called The
Collective Memory, which
I think is one of the
great books of our time.
And I will refer to
excerpts a bit later.
Rossi secondly divides
the city timewise
into primary elements
and dwellings.
When dwellings are expressions
of ever-changing individual
will, they constitute the
vernacular architecture
that is subject to changes
in use, form, and meaning.
In contrast,
primary elements are
expressions of collective
will, especially
the subgroup of monuments.
So housing is temporary.
A neighborhood may be
permanent as a primary element.
I quote from him.
"A monument's
persistence or permanence
is a result of its
capacity to constitute
the city, its history, and
art, its being and memory."
I've given you a copy
of his project in Padua,
the Palazzo della
Ragione, which was,
he argues, an example
of a monument--
these pages here.
He goes on to use the term locus
to specify a particular space
or place in the
city, which forms
a part of its permanent history.
And his argument is
the city needs to be
built on these permanences.
All new permanences should
be created at the same time
as maintaining fluidity in
the dispensing of housing.
He makes the bold statement
that permanence in form
precedes permanence
in institutions.
I quote, "The permanence
of a form or its value
as a reference is entirely
independent on both
the specific functions
for which it was designed,
and its [INAUDIBLE]
with a continuity
of urban institutions.
For this reason I'm
deliberately emphasizing
the form and the architecture
of the city, rather than
its institutions."
I mean, primitively, he's
saying that an old building can
take a different
use without changing
its form significantly.
In fact, in the
history-memory distinction,
he controverts the normal
history-memory relationship
over time.
Normally, somebody like
David Lowenthal in the book
The Past Is a Foreign
Country-- one of the best
books on architecture
preservation, by the way,
says that typically,
memory is short-lived,
and it's replaced by the
permanence of history.
Rossi reverts the two.
He says history occurs as
long as a building maintains
its present use.
Memory occurs, is instituted
once the use changes.
These are abstract ideas.
I don't know how much empirical
evidence there is for this,
or how much Rossi has measured
the permanence of institutions
as opposed to the
permanence of monuments.
It doesn't matter.
Rossi is valuable because
he attracts attention
to the distinction in value
of certain forms of the city.
I had an argument
with Kevin Lynch
about Aldo Rossi saying
this, and I'll just
quote Lynch from his own writing
about his antagonism to Rossi.
You can make up your own mind.
"For Rossi, architecture is an
autonomous discipline, eternal,
outside of time,
creating form typologies
which have an independent
existence like Platonic cities.
The city is a
permanent structure
through which it remembers
its past, it realizes itself.
These attitudes unfold into
monstrous, seductive flowers.
They are rooted in
the same false idea
that man and his
habitat are completely
separate entities,
linked only, if at all,
by some mechanical
one-directional causation."
It's true that Rossi says in his
writing that form has meaning.
Form creates certain things.
I'm using [INAUDIBLE]
remembers its past.
I think I have to give Rossi the
benefit of not being so dumb as
to believe that
bricks have a brain,
or stone remembers anything.
He's doing a syllogistic jump.
I think syllogistic
is the right word.
He's assuming that you assume.
That it's the mental
interpretation of what--
when Louis Kahn says, and
as he often used to say,
something makes itself.
He's not referring to
the mechanical system
which produces light.
He's referring to the
human understanding
of the mechanical system
which produces light.
He's compressing the idea.
So I think Kevin is
wrong, and I told him so.
But he didn't agree with me.
Poor man, he's not alive
any longer to fight.
I think you have to
read Rossi now, and make
an independent decision of
how much that book means.
I don't think you need to
look at his other books
or to biography of an idea.
Certainly, don't look
at any of his projects,
or go to one of them
immediately and be
appalled by the stupidity
of the thinking.
Leon Krier is a much more
indomitable character.
He automatically classifies.
He makes absolute judgments.
For him, classical architecture
is the only architecture
that one should contemplate
independent of economy, time,
culture, et cetera--
technology.
He also assumes that
equally stark judgments
can be made between
public buildings
and private buildings.
For me, the genius of much
of the complexity of urbanism
is the overlapping between
public and private entities
in space.
If I drove down Memorial
Drive and got to Mount Auburn
Hospital and looked at
the school across the way,
which my children went to--
I had to pay an anomalous
amount of money to that school.
So therefore, it must
be a private school.
But it looks like any
school down there.
If I go down Mount Auburn Street
and come through Watertown,
there's a classical
facade facing me which
happens to be a public school.
In England, a public
is a private school.
In American, a public
school is a public school.
What classifications--
I will deal
with the dichotomy
or the dialectic
between public and private in
city form in Thursday's class.
Krier can be criticized
on many levels.
First of all, the
universality of classicism
is a political assumption.
I don't know if Indians and
Gandhi assume classicism
to be a universal form.
Certainly, I never grew up
in South Africa regarding
classicism as the
appropriate form
to satisfy Black
ambitions in South Africa.
Classicism was always the
form of superior buildings.
When I went to the low courts,
it had a classical pediment.
When I went to visit a
political friend of mine
in Johannesburg's
prison, I entered
under a classical entablature.
Classicism for me
growing up was associated
with values which were
eternal and beyond my reality
as a young person.
I'm not sure I've ever outgrown
those versions of classicism.
We have conflicts about
this version of the past.
I said this before, but the
Boston Symphony always--
they always used to play--
I mean, there's a
concert I want to go
to New York in which Gustavo
Dudamel, the young conductor
of the Los Angeles
Philharmonic Orchestra,
is conducting
Bruckner's Number 8.
If it is a classical
symphony, which
is all of the overtures
of classicism,
it's Bruckner Number 8.
But he is playing
preliminary to it a piece
by a composer called Corigliano,
a contemporary composer.
The weight of the
piece is in Bruckner.
So there is a part of us which
establishes in our culture
certain values about
the past as absolute,
and certain values
about the present as OK.
We are constantly, in
my view of the world,
balancing these
two problematics,
coming to a satisfying
conclusions,
even arguing that Mozart's
piano concertos when he returned
to Vienna started accounting for
the popular impulse in music.
And Number 26 is a
wonderful, popular version
of his earlier piano concerto.
I don't know how to leave you
with this Leon Krier position.
I'll show you some slides.
Look at Poundbury.
The image I've given you is
from the 1976 La Villette
competition in which he
won the second Prize.
I won't show that to
you in the slides.
It's the last pages of--
In many respects, if you look
at this project in detail--
particularly the
drawings, he draws,
and his wife draws, beautifully.
In order to create enough
identity in a 15,000-person,
place even at this density,
he has to introduce a linear
system down the middle, full
of large buildings, hotels,
convention centers.
No 15,000 part of a city
can support economically
this kind of program.
One of the problems that
the new urbanists have
is that in American
densities, if you were not
willing to walk more
than seven minutes,
you can drive to a
7-Eleven and a video store,
let alone to the
diversity of shopping
or commercial
opportunities that you have
if you increase the density.
Suburbia is fraught
with the problem
of having too few people.
You can inflate it
as much as you can.
The second problem with
this clear preoccupation
with classicism is that it
doesn't allow for diversity.
The piece I quoted from
myself, in discussion
with Leon Krier at one
meeting, argues that argument.
Let's go on, because I don't
want to run out of time,
to discussion of memory.
We know a lot more about
memory than we used to.
Across the street, there
are bunch of people.
One of the institutes
is the institute
for memory, the
Picower Institute.
What we know about
memory is that it
operates through
the existence of 10
to the power of 12 neurons.
And what is 10 to
the power of 12?
That's the number of
neurons in the human brain.
Each neuron is connected to
plus-minus 5,000 other cells.
So you have a network
of immense power.
50% of memory is created--
not memory, I'm
sorry, on perception.
Vision commands almost one
half of our brain's cortex.
To make sense of a picture
that you see through your eyes
takes half the power.
This requires more
computational power
than the MIT engineers can
fathom, let alone produce.
Nancy Kanwisher, a
professor across the street,
writes the following.
I'm quoting her because I
don't want to make mistakes.
"Object recognition
is no trivial task,
because the visual image doesn't
enter our brains as a developed
photograph."
Imagine that most of
architectural expression
that I'm talking about is
processed by the visual brain.
"Rather, it is like
a grid of pixels
on a digital camera, an
array of millions of numbers
indicating light and color
on our eyes' 10 million
or so photoreceptors.
As you walk down
the street, billions
of bits of visual information
strike your field of view.
That view refreshes itself
continuously as objects move,
lighting changes, or you
shift your eyes or your body.
Still, the briefest
glance is often
enough to recognize even a
never-before-seen objects.
In a fraction of a
second, its visual input
runs from the retina through
increasing the [INAUDIBLE]
of the visual stream until it
reaches the cognitive regions
of the brain."
I'm amazed at this.
Processing of visual
information is not automatic.
It is selective.
What you decide to send to
the higher parts of your brain
is based on the selection you
make in the image you see.
Memory is very
difficult to deal with.
We know it exists
because we have access
to the cells of the individual.
But what is collective memory?
I'm going to go through
a bunch of theses.
Let's see if I can goes through
those lists of distinctions.
Here, I'm giving you a
list of five writers who've
tried to distinguish
history and memory.
Number 1, "When history ends,
memory begins," Aldo Rossi.
History precedes
memory-- his argument
is that when a building
changes its function,
it invokes memory and ends
history, which is nonsense.
Maurice Halbwachs
says, general history
only starts when tradition
ends and the social memory
is folding or breaking up.
This is the conventional
interpretation.
Memory, if it is as
Halbwachs argues, the result
of social interaction.
Halbwachs is very outspoken.
He writes a chapter on musical
memory, which is extraordinary.
He argues that it is impossible
to maintain musical memory
without being part of a group.
I am often amazed that a
pianist like Mauricio Pollini
will walk onto a stage
and play for three hours
without looking at a note.
He'll play from Beethoven,
he'll play from Chopin,
he'll play from--
well, whoever he plays from.
We still don't know, because
we can't penetrate the brain
medically.
You can do it only if
you operate on tumors,
but you cannot--
most of disease is
understood through symptoms
or through blood measurements.
You can get neither very
directly from the brain.
So the brain is the last
part of the human body that
is subject to
research in medicine,
and the distance it
has to go particularly
for the neurodegenerative
diseases--
Alzheimer's, Parkinson's,
autism, schizophrenia,
is long, long away,
although they are doing
good work across the street.
So these assumptions about
memory are approximations.
The only person who has a
very strong view on this
is Pierre Nora the
French philosopher,
who says, "Memory is life born
by living societies founded
in its name.
History, on the other hand,
is the reconstruction,
always problematic
and incomplete,
of what is no longer.
History is perpetually
suspicious of memory,
and its true mission is to
suppress and destroy it."
This is very antagonistic
view of history's claim
to coincide with memory,
time separating the two.
He argues that
colonization is based
on destroying the
memory component
of native civilizations.
He also says that postmodernism,
with false history,
fake history, sound
bites, virtual history,
compounds the problem.
Let's look at some of this
material a little more
carefully.
History has a long association--
sorry, architecture has a
long association with memory.
The mnemonic device
for remembering
is absolutely present in
the earliest histories.
Memory is quoted in
by Cicero and others
as occurring when the Greek
Simonedes is at a meeting,
and leaves the meeting
because he's cold outside.
While he's outside,
the building's roof
collapses and kills
everybody in the room.
He has a capacity of memory,
which reconstructs everybody,
although the bodies
are disfigured.
The notion that if
that act of memory
was an important
phenomenon [INAUDIBLE]
classical societies
is made evident
by the role that mnemonics
played in Greek education.
Young men would walk--
not women, young men would
walk around the pyramid,
and they're concentrating
on the [INAUDIBLE]
the architectural
elements of the system.
They'd walk round
and round and roun
until it imprinted their minds.
They were open to question
about the constructions
of the orders.
Young men were taught to
debate using architecture
as a mnemonic.
You make an argument.
You enter into the
foyer of the building.
You make your argument.
You turn right into a room.
That's your sub-argument.
You return to the main argument.
You go to the left.
You make another
second sub-argument.
You return to the center.
You go up a staircase.
You go to the third of the left.
You return to the main argument.
You go to the fourth, and so on.
This is a very classical
form of learning.
But when memory was not
available through television
or through radio or through
telephones and so on,
it was a very
precious commodity.
And architecture as a space
is an important mnemonic.
Architecture serves
as a memory system
for ideas about human
origins, a means for recording
understanding of order and
relationship in the world,
and an attempt to grasp the
concept of the internal cosmos,
which has no fixed dimensions
with neither beginning nor end.
There are endless references
to the use of mnemonics.
Frances Yates' book
on memory and culture
refers to medieval
systems of theater
writing as
mnemonics-- as devices
for learning about memory.
John Ruskin, the 19th
century British art historian
and philosopher,
writes, "We may remember
without [INAUDIBLE] memory.
We may live without memory
and worship without memory.
But we--" sorry.
Ruskin wrote a book called
Seven Lamps of Architecture,
which none of you
know about, I'm sure.
It's a book.
Good. how do you know about it?
AUDIENCE: I took a
class on the history
of conservation [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN BEINART: Seven Lamps
of Architecture-- sacrifice,
truth, power, beauty,
life, memory, obedience.
Why would a 19th century
British art historian
include memory as one of
the lamps of architecture?
We cannot remember without her.
These are obsessive arguments.
But the whole apparatus of
the built world is a mnemonic.
It's way of us maintaining
our daily life.
This is Halbwachs' big point.
I'll come to it in one minute.
I'm trying to go through the
others as quickly as I can.
The arguments about-- in
Jacques [INAUDIBLE] book about--
and in Yale professor
Kirsten Harris'
writing about the
phenomenon of paradise.
Paradise Lost is explicit
in its mission to us
that we have been trying
to recreate paradise.
[INAUDIBLE] paradise
refers to that.
[INAUDIBLE] philosophers
have written
about the loss of paradise.
Paradise Lost Who wrote the
epic poem Paradise Lost?
Milton, Yeah.
I was confusing
with somebody else.
Harris also argues that we are
the only animal species that
knows that we're going to die.
Therefore, our capacity
to be beholden to time
is greater, this phenomenon
of the building of ruins.
The single appearance
of artificial--
how do you explain the
building of artificial ruins
in the 18th century, given
my argument about memory?
What is a sophisticated society?
What is the wealthy and
the sophisticated society
in [INAUDIBLE] building
ruins on the property?
We go to Louis Kahn, whom I
quote in my writing on memory.
In the Hurva synagogue, which
was number 3, which is probably
Louis Kahn's half
dozen best creations,
although it wasn't
built, he was asked
to replace the traditional
Jewish synagogue
in the old city of Jerusalem.
He refused the rabbi's
implication and said,
I'm going to build it
on the site next to it.
I'm going to maintain the ruins.
Why did he argue for
maintaining the ruins?
First rule, Kahn says
ruins maintain memory.
What is not built
is not really lost.
Second, a ruin free
of the obligation
to perform active
functions any longer
is able to fully express
its spirit or formations,
often more so than
whole buildings.
A third aspect of
Kahn's thought is
his linking of ruins
with the idea of silence.
And then the fourth, his concept
of the fact that contemporary
built forms could be given
metaphoric implications
of ruins.
The creation of a
perfect paradise
lies at the center
of architecture.
Paradise on Earth
is a kind of waiting
room-- an anticipatory
suburb of kingdom come.
Maurice Halbwachs
remarks that [INAUDIBLE]
is first and foremost
due to the fact
that physical objects
of our daily contact
change little or not
at all, providing us
with an image of
permanence and stability.
If I had to find my mirror
to shave in the morning,
in a different place
every day, I'd go mad.
I wouldn't shave.
If Memorial Drive changed
its function overnight,
and I had to find a new road
to come to MIT every morning,
I'd go mad.
Guy de Maupassant
tells a horrible story
of a mother and daughter
who come to Paris
during the plague epidemic.
The mother doesn't know that
the daughter has plague.
She hasn't-- they check into a
hotel where they reserved room.
The manager of the
hotel recognizes
the plague in the daughter.
The mother and
daughter check in,
go out to see doctors
for the rest of the day.
The manager of the
hotel has their room
changed while they're gone--
redecorated.
Their belongings are dispatched.
They return that night,
and the manager tells them
that they made a mistake.
They didn't check
into the hotel.
Guy de Maupassant
writes the story
to intrigue us about the need
for permanence [INAUDIBLE]
about the everyday fact of
checking into a hotel providing
us with reasonable
expectations or nourishment.
Halbwachs is very full of this.
I'll just quote
him in one place.
"Thus every collective
memory unfolds
within the spatial framework.
Space is a reality that endures.
Since our impressions
rush by one after another
and leave nothing
behind in the mind,
we can understand how
we recapture the past,
but only by understanding
how it is in effect preserved
by our physical surrounding.
It is to space, the space
we occupy, traverse,
have continual access
to, or can at any time
reconstruct in
thought or imagination
that we must turn our attention.
Our thought must focus on
it if this or that category
of remembrance is to reappear."
OK, running out
of time as always.
Jesus Christ.
Can't do two lectures in one.
[INAUDIBLE] I just had a
few important things to say.
Not important things to
say, but a few things,
and it's quarter till 2:00.
There are 30 slides
in each tray,
so we're not going to make it.
What I suggest is that
I'll give you enough stuff
to ponder about and read about.
We'll take a break, look at
the slides in the first half
of Thursday's
class, and I'll just
shorten Thursday's class a bit.
This always happens at
the end of the semester.
We'll now look at one of the
categories of transference
of tectonic forms literally
to a new building.
James Ingo Freed writes
about the Holocaust museum.
"I prefer memory to history
because I prefer the authentic
to the reconstructed."
History is reconstructed.
Critics of history
are always assuming
that it's reconstructed.
That it's based upon
somebody else's measurements
and thought, not the
intuitive impressions that you
create in your own brain.
Althouth, as Halbwachs points
out, relying on society.
"History erases detail
at a painful cost.
It gains consistency through
abstraction and [INAUDIBLE]
the loss of the
richness of life.
As a physical artifact
of a given time,
place, and culture,
architectures
an undistorted, unchanged
thread of memory woven
into the tapestry of history."
What he says he's trying to do--
and we'll see in the images.
"I discovered that the only
way for me into the Holocaust
was through both the
tectonics of the Holocaust
and an invented
tectonics of my own.
There was an architecture
of the Holocaust
with its own tectonics
that surround the surface."
What he's saying
is that the source
of what he wishes to
memorialize has a tectonic form.
He can abstract some
of those tectonics
and reproduce them in
the current version
of the building.
What are those forms?
Steel, bricks, the use
of space, the clustering
of the sequence in which
you go through the museum.
You know that you go
up before you go down.
Certain artifacts, such as the
little town which was destroyed
and all the images plastered
on the ceiling, little devices
which--
the elevated
passageways which have
diagonal structural
reinforcement.
All of these are
tectonic items which
are meant to meld the
present and the past,
meant to inflict themselves
on your memory in a way
that you are [INAUDIBLE]
with what you're
seeing as an actual event.
It's very difficult to know
about when this is crap
or whether this is
fundamentally powerful stuff.
We are in an age where
distortions are so absolute
and borrowing is so absolute
through virtual media that
[INAUDIBLE] is a
genuine article--
a genuine borrowing is
difficult to evaluate.
But I've experienced
the museum a couple
of times partly as an architect,
partly as just as a citizen.
The remarkable
thing is that you go
through the disposition of
evidence, very clinically,
almost historically
accurate evidence.
The dates of every
single item are.
Included the mechanical railroad
car that took Jews to Auschwitz
is actually there, or
when America turned down
the boat of immigrants,
that's there.
Then you go down and you leave
the building through a room.
And the room is just
based on the voices
of people who were
in Auschwitz talking
about things like,
my mother said to me,
don't worry about the food.
You eat the food.
I have had enough already.
I knew my mother they
had nothing to eat,
but she was wanting
me to survive.
The poignancy of that
material touches your memory.
It evokes your own
experience with your mother
in Freudian terms.
So in the piece of
writing I've given to you,
Stan Anderson writes a
piece at a conference which
I ran in 1994 about memory.
And Freed and the
French philosopher
whom I quoted
about memory seemed
to indicate that we have this
bifocal impression, knowledge
of the past--
history which is categorical
and empirical and selected
by other people, an apparently
objective rendition of my past,
and my own rendition of
my past, which is lively,
irregular, full of obstacles,
full of juxtapositions.
Like Freud says, I
can't externalize what
I remember visually very well.
I could draw my mother next to
my daughter and my grandmother
and the woman I
see in my dreams,
but I can't put them
all together as I
can in my psychic experience.
There's a politics of memory,
the Jews maintaining memory
through the book, through
the remembrance of Jerusalem
on an annual ritual,
and so on and so on.
I gave you this piece
from The Boston Globe,
which is interesting, because
it's a selective memory
situation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Oh, yeah.
Sorry, I'll give
you the references.
Mass xeroxing often
cuts out the top.
It's a critique of Rossi's
book written by, I think,
Francesco [INAUDIBLE] And
I'll give you the reference.
At this time of these textile
mills in Lowell, one of us
here thought how
wonderful it would
be if we could put the new
University of Massachusetts
branch.
Where's Lowell?
Lowell's in
Massachusetts, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JULIAN BEINART: Into
these old buildings.
And we were all doing
sketches in studios
showing how wonderful
it would be to do this.
Here's a man who says
those memories were awful.
What are you memorizing things
of the past that we find awful?
It's a memory, again,
selectively experienced.
How you, as a professional,
condition your own memory with
the memory [INAUDIBLE] people,
presumably such a lively
function that the only
thing you can do is--
in this memory world,
there's some strange things.
There's an MCP thesis done in
which the student was a trained
philosopher--
a phenomenologist.
And he wrote about
his parents' apartment
in New York and growing
up, and his reactions when
they changed the room when
he left to go to college
and rented the room.
His whole thesis was
based upon his dreams.
Fact is, it was a lie.
He never had those dreams.
He reinvented the
dreams for his thesis.
So it was a complex
mixture of data.
He should have been failed,
but nobody knew the reality
until he told us afterwards.
But it was such a
brilliant set of occasions,
of being two foot tall and
seeing the refrigerator
and what it meant.
Seeing the large bed that his
mother and father slept in,
and wondering why they
needed such a large bed,
and dreaming of
interpolations of that
as remembered by an adult
and what that would mean
for architecture understanding.
Anyway.
I won't be able
to deal with some
of the examples
from Washington as
well as I would showing
the history of monuments
in Washington.
The amazing thing is that
none of the classical features
of monuments were maintained
since the Vietnam Memorial.
A couple of things
have happened.
Number one, the World
War II Memorial,
there's a neoclassical
construction--
a Leon Krier construction
with absolutely no
merit at all, other than
in the merit of nostalgia.
Maya Lin's Vietnam Memorial
is an extraordinary adventure.
It takes the idea of
connecting a monument
to individual
experience by putting
the names of the people.
Your grandson will be able to
go to that name in 25 years time
or 100 years time.
Ross Perot's
objection and the need
to add a soldier a
figure at the entrance
is a stupid attempt to add
nostalgia to the abstraction.
The power of monuments often
lies in its abstraction,
in its being of
cleansed of irrelevance.
The obelisk of Washington,
I will show you
a slide that in the 19th
century, people in Washington--
certain people wanted to
garnish the obelisk memorial
with evidence of the
inner decoration.
What has happened
in recent times
is that we've lost the capacity,
it seems in architecture,
to memorialize through objects,
through forms themselves.
AUDIENCE: Is that because
we're lacking the capacity
to see beyond the evidence?
JULIAN BEINART: I don't know.
I wish I could answer that.
The version of the Roosevelt
Memorial, which is a garden,
dispenses with the
need of architecture.
The three versions of
the Roosevelt Memorial,
which I will have shown you,
are large slabs of stone.
From stone to garden is
one of the ways in which
American culture dispenses
with things it can't deal with,
or has inadequate solutions for.
Nature's always
there to accommodate.
If you lose in
man-made construction,
nature is always there.
That's why I have my doubts
about the constant evocation
of nature.
Nature's too friendly a partner
when examined superficially.
We'll look at some of
these images on Thursday
and see if we can remember
the arguments we made.
The left diagram is
from Rossi's book.
In fact, both diagrams
are from Rossi's book.
You will recall, Rossi
argues a number of themes--
one about the relationship
between the city
of the mind and the built city;
number two, between permanences
and temporary parts
of cities; thirdly,
be the relationship between
institutions and forms,
and so on and so on.
Essentially, his argument is
that the ideas and examples
fossilized in the city which
are worth excavating and using
is a template for future growth.
The Palazzo [INAUDIBLE]
on the left,
destroyed by a hurricane in
1956 and rebuilt with different
uses, but maintaining
its place in the city.
The example on the right
is Carlo Fontana's attempt
to make the Colosseum into
a church, the argument,
again, that the
framework of the form
is significant in realizing
an institutional change
from the killing of
Christians to the celebrating
of the life of Jesus.
It doesn't seem to matter.
Next.
OK.
This is [INAUDIBLE] in France.
The influence of the permanence
of the surrounding wall
in Lucca, the Roman
Forum, as an antecedent
to the most important
public place in the city.
Next.
Spalato in the
former Yugoslavia.
An example of the slow--
this is Hadrian's palace, which
is slowly and over time taken
up by other people and invaded.
And the invasion and the
subsequent disjunction
between what is there in the
past and what is now built
is of interest to Rossi.
This slide on the right is
from the Architettura Razionale
exhibition in Rome.
I don't know the date.
It's an important image.
It's public housing
or social housing
on Karl-Marx-Allee in at
that time East Berlin.
The argument is that
locus is significant,
even if the
architectural form isn't.
As the argument would go,
this is the equivalent
of putting social housing
on Fifth Avenue in New York.
By manifesting locus, or
the importance of location,
you send important
messages not only
about the form of the city, but
the meaning of its retention.
Next.
The project in Gallaratesse,
a housing project in Milano,
designed by Aymonino
and Aldo Rossi
has this extraordinary
empty set of spaces
underneath the
housing on the right.
The idea is that people
who are migrating
to live in this housing in the
north used to live above shops.
This is a theme which, if
you're ever interested,
you should look at
[INAUDIBLE] and look
at Giancarlo De Carlo's project
in Matera, which I showed you
very briefly, where he
makes a point of maintaining
the shopping
underneath the housing.
Here, Rossi does an
abstraction of it.
There is no need for
shopping in this project.
So he relies on people's
memory, and gives them
enough clues apparently to
situate virtual shopping
in this space, which is--
it's a crazy idea, but
he does crazy things.
It's also in line with
his own architecture,
which has reduced alphabet
of forms as the basis
for making new things.
Next.
I was going to show
you two projects
in San Francisco, which have
relied on the idea of locus
in redeveloping.
On the left is the plan of the
Berkeley cooperative society,
which owns the land on the right
of the [INAUDIBLE] Building,
and it wishes to
engage in building
public housing on the property.
The architects, Marvin
Buchanan and Donlyn Lyndon,
argue that replacing
all the buildings
would delete the important
elements of the existing
context.
The second thing is that, unlike
public housing where people
are moved from where they
are to somewhere else,
this maintains the
possibility of maintaining
the place of where these people
are in relation to the Berkeley
campus just down the road.
Next.
By choosing to build
public housing in such
a contorted site, it
demands the introduction
of more diverse forms
of housing than normal.
This slide on the left shows
the attempt to maintain a tree
and build around it.
On the right is the
community celebration
for the opening of the housing.
The point here is
that the locus is
the relationship in
space between a place
and its surroundings.
Building on that, or creating
a new version of that idea,
is essentially what
this place has done.
Next.
This is a project on
the edge of Chinatown
in San Francisco at the corner
of Stockton and Sacramento
Street.
It's a very steeply
sloping site, which
went through three versions.
The first version had
told two tall towers.
And the basement
and the elevation
on Stockton Street, which is the
main street through Chinatown,
was given over to
parking and to shops.
This was during
Richard Nixon's time.
Richard Nixon needed votes
in California, rather than
San Francisco, rather badly,
and the federal government
allowed this project to
go through two stages.
So helped by the local
community churches,
the project ultimately
resulted in two lower towers,
both for the Chinese
social housing,
and the ground floor
turned over to a community
center and a daycare
center, and the parking
limited to Chinese groups.
Just further up the
hill is Nob Hill,
which is some of the most
expensive housing in San
Francisco.
This is the opening
of the housing.
Halfway up the hill,
the project has
a plane, which is only a
horizontal plane available.
And that is made
into a public space
at the center of the housing.
Next.
You can see the slope looking
downwards and the diagram
on the right.
This is all published in
Society & Space for those of you
interested in researching
this any further.
Next.
Another contemporary version
of the issue of locus
is through the highly publicized
invention of the marketplace.
Michael Sorkin is rather
nasty about most things,
calls it a happy
festival place, implying
that you have to be happy
to enjoy the world of this
[INAUDIBLE] In both projects,
which maintain the site,
the notion of the program
is maintained as well.
Food becomes the
basis of the new site.
And although the food is
highly selective and priced
to a market of a
singular kind, there's
is not much diversity
of population or places
in this environment.
Next.
This is South
Street Seaport done
by the same
architects as Faneuil
[INAUDIBLE] Marketplace.
Here again, it's building
on the locus, if you want,
of the existing fish market.
Next.
A third version of
this comparatively
is Pike Place in Seattle.
Pike Place in Seattle has been
memorialized by the painter
Mark Tobey on the right and the
existing market on the left.
This was a market where
farmers would bring produce
into the town, and
people would buy directly
from the market here.
There would be no middleman,
no second order clientele.
In Faneuil Marketplace,
we have British tea sold,
which is a commodity so removed
from any direct relationship
between consumer and producer.
Here, the tradition is
established in these images.
Next.
Threatened by urban renewal,
the project on the left
determines to remove the
vestiges of the market
altogether.
And public opposition, organized
by some of the university
faculty, maintain the idea
of keeping the quality
of a public market as a place.
Next.
We'll go through a number
of diverse examples.
Here is the apparatus for
achieving dual meaning.
On the left is Church
Court at the intersection
of Mass Avenue
and Beacon Street,
where you can, in one
image next to each other,
see the contemporary
housing and the old church.
Remember my quotation from
Freud, that in spatial terms,
you have to separate out images.
You cannot have the same
content in one image.
Here, they are separated out.
The example on the right
is also from Boston.
It's in Newton,
where a restaurant
has taken over church.
Churches are seen to be benign
institutions for accommodating
new communal uses.
We had a student here tried
to do the thesis in Toronto
on taking a meat
abattoir building
and turning it into
a housing, and trying
to deal with the
stigma of making
housing [INAUDIBLE] which
was considered unattractive.
Next.
An example of a significant
environmental Rouge plant
in Detroit memorialized
in a number
of ways by Sheeler's
photographs on the right--
next-- by being the home of the
Model T, the first automobile.
Also, the first workers strike
and the formation of a trade
union, and an amplitude
of notions which
should be memorialized.
But the absence
of any Rouge plant
is so large, that there's
nothing to be done.
There's no use for the Rouge
plant in contemporary Detroit.
So this is an example where
what should be memorialized
is lost in the absence
of a new program.
Next.
This is the Bicocca
competition in Milano
on the site of the large
Pirelli tire factory,
which has moved out, leaving
a lot of infrastructure
and a [INAUDIBLE] which
is subject to competition
where almost all the leading
architects the world were
invited to submit entries.
I'm going to select two
entries to compare them.
On the right is
Giancarlo De Carlo's On
the left is the site plan.
On the right is Giancarlo
De Carlo version.
Using a large number of
the existing buildings,
the whole idea is that
programmatically this
would become, in Italian,
a new technological pole--
P-O-L-E. It's only something
Italians can understand.
What it's meant to be is some
kind of new electronic product
management enterprise.
Giancarlo uses a large number
of the existing streets
and buildings, and introduces
new elements where needed.
Next.
Gabetti and Isola, a firm
of architects from Torino,
came second in the
competition, do
something which is interesting.
They go back to find that
the Romans plow the land--
organize the land in a
diagonal set of forms.
And they start working
on this hidden geometry,
and develop a plan based
upon the hidden geometry
of the Roman land.
Next.
If they then
transfer their design
into the world of ecology,
it's a green set of buildings.
All of the notions
of other buildings
should be environmentally
controlled and rationed
and so on is part of the design.
The issue that is
interesting here
is, how do you connect
hidden references
to existing conditions?
Who would know the connection
between the Roman fields
and the new buildings?
How would you know that?
How as an architect
do you make--
you can put up a poster
or a bronze plaque
telling the story?
But you can't have
the two contents
simultaneously available.
We are encumbered, unlike Freud.
According to Freud,
we as architects,
who are spatialists,
are encumbered
by not being able to
simultaneously produce
an experience as presumably
you can in the human brain.
Next.
A similar stupid proposition.
Not stupid proposition, but
more stupid than Gabetti
and Isola's work.
They actually are
very good architects.
And I think in the
Bicocca competition,
this is the most
interesting projection.
This is from a studio
at the Harvard GSD.
The site is Columbus.
Where's Columbus, Ohio?
Yes.
This is where Eisenman is
going to build an art museum.
He digs deep down
under the ground
to find that this was an
Indian burial ground originally
on which the Americans
built Camp Sherman, an army
camp, on which the town
of Chillicothe was built.
And now it's become Columbus.
So there are four layers of
geometry, one above the other.
So by the use of
the term scaling,
he devises a method of
slowly retrieving the traces
from underneath upwards.
Next.
Through a series of geometrical
moves to ultimately induce
a solution for the museum.
The problem again is the same
one as the Bicocca competition
problem.
What is the record of your
invention made public?
How available is
the relationship
between your final
product and your work?
Who in heaven's name would
know the relationship
as an outside experience?
In any case, what is the point
of digging for inspiration
under the ground when
you have [INAUDIBLE]
atrophy of
conventional geometries
to use for architecture?
What is the advantage?
It's a problematic question.
Nobody at the GSD
asked the question.
This became a wonderful game.
There is no virgin
territory in this sense.
Everything has an underneath
evocation of some use.
It's landscape
urbanism penetrating
beneath the skin
of the landscape
into some territory, which is
enough to gestate new forms.
Next.
This [INAUDIBLE] work
on the grid of Chicago,
producing this through a
series of exercises, scaling
and transmission,
is equally stupid.
Mixed.
Not stupid-- intellectually
interesting, but so what.
This is not a painting class.
Do you need to know-- when
you look at a painting of Van
Gogh's painted when he was in
asylum in the south of France,
and he painted through a
particular window looking
across the landscape, you
don't know this background.
You just look at the painting.
The painting has to
have enough in itself
that the history is redundant.
Who goes to an art
exhibition and demands
that they understand the
history of each painting?
How much of the history is part
of the experience of the art?
I'm asking you a question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
You cannot really appreciate
a Japanese sword katana done
by [INAUDIBLE] without knowing
the context in which it was
made.
JULIAN BEINART:
No, I understand.
That's what we have museums for.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: An
art production--
sorry, an art production should
be able to stand on its own,
independent of the knowledge
of the culture and so on.
That's my own sense
of the capacity
that we all have to
abstract from form ideas.
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain different layers
of meaning [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: You
might-- now, as I
said before, in looking
at a Van Gogh painting,
you may well want to go
back to his drawings.
You want to read his
letters to his brother.
You want to understand his
epilepsy, and so on and so on.
But essentially, given the
canvas in front of you,
it should have enough content.
You can increase the content,
but it cannot be totally
dependent on your ability
to connect backwards.
These examples we
just looked at,
from Eisenman and
Gabetti and Isola,
depend on your ability to--
there's no evidence.
Well, the new building
may be a consummate work
of art, in which case reference
backward is immaterial.
But as a device for
creating urbanism,
it's a difficult argument.
I'll concede the
difficulty of the argument.
When Haydn uses the data
of his wife's birthday
as the beginning
of some music, does
the music quality
depend on you knowing
that it was the
trivialization which
caused him to write the music--
a trivial beginning?
I tend to argue in
favor of what you
see being able to be
explained by what you see.
AUDIENCE: Julian, we had in in
Politecnico di Milano an entire
class for one year that was
about retracing the [INAUDIBLE]
and then doing a project
[INAUDIBLE] But I would say,
all my education in
Italy was-- like,
urban design education was
strongly based on retracing
former traces or ruins of
whatever was previously,
and then integrating them into
the [INAUDIBLE] It was the word
[INAUDIBLE] was
oriented towards--
JULIAN BEINART: So it means
you can't build in America.
AUDIENCE: It means that I felt
really lost when I came here,
and then there was [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN BEINART: But
I'm just showing you
that Eisenman found four
layers in Columbus, Ohio.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But it's-- yes,
[INAUDIBLE] like that.
JULIAN BEINART:
There are no doubt
instances where retrieving
ideas from the past
is significant in
connecting you to something
interesting about the future.
This comes up very often.
AUDIENCE: There shouldn't
be a restriction,
because if you just need
to anchor it to the past,
that means that there
is no room for a fully
original idea from scratch.
So it needn't be--
[INAUDIBLE] to be
exclusive in nature.
JULIAN BEINART: Well, I
wonder how many people
have original ideas
from scratch, anyway.
We all beleaguered by knowledge.
Some is explicit, so is not.
I don't know exactly
why I draw my hand,
and draw in a particular way.
Neither did Picasso.
I mean, he drew in 70,000 ways.
Sometimes, it's
clear [INAUDIBLE]
art historians to show
what he was trying to do.
Sometimes, he just draws with a
hidden vocabulary of knowledge.
It's a contentious issue.
All I'm trying to argue
is that these examples all
try to connect you to
previous knowledge.
AUDIENCE: Because of the
preservation that they want--
it's all about preservation,
your view and your perspective
on that, I guess.
And I don't think during
our education in the US,
we don't have so
much focus on that.
JULIAN BEINART: No.
Understandably, if
you grew up in Italy,
it's a little difficult to
bypass the extraordinary things
that have been done.
If you grew up in
Greece, of course--
Georgeas is not here today.
He grew up in Greece.
I wonder what you would
make of reconstructing
the Agora as an item worth
generating a new vocabulary.
Have you been to
the Agora in Athens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
No, I'm thinking of
the Agora particularly,
because it's such an
extraordinary difficult
phenomenon--
37 acres of land to invoke.
The Romans-- [INAUDIBLE] was a
much easier literal formulation
to seek adaptations from.
The Greeks didn't
believe in the cardinal.
There is no cardinality in
the Agora in Athens There
no organization based upon
a simple precept, such
as you need a horizontal line
and a vertical line to cross.
This is complex
territory, and I'm
not enough of an art historian
to take this further.
Let's move to Leon Krier.
First of all, there is stupid
distinction between res privata
and res publica.
In the next class,
which we'll do
in this start in the second
half after these pictures,
I'll try to show you how
inappropriate this distinction
is.
For him, a good city is one
in which the public domain is
evidenced through a series
of architectural forms
which deviate really
from classical form,
or deviate, which are
determined by their allegiance
to classical form.
Next.
The world of the private are
really rectangular boxes.
A good city is
one which combines
the two, in which the public
is signally differentiated
from the private.
What happens if you
are wealthy and you
want to put a classical arch
in the front of your house,
I don't know.
But let's leave that example.
Next.
The use of classicism in this
project of his for an island
resort off the coast of Africa.
It aims to recreate
a context borrowed
from a significant past.
It may be exotic enough
to attract people
looking for another
experience in life, even
if it's quixotic and veneer
and lacking in originality.
But then, who cares what
the original consequence
of classical architecture was?
Next.
When it's taken seriously,
such as by Prince Charles
and his confreres
in England, you
see a political
argument made in favor
of Canaletto's version of London
and what London has become.
According to Prince
Charles, London
has been brutalized by
modern architecture.
Next.
So Richmond Terrace on
the left on the Thames
is an office complex designed
by Quinlan Terry, who
works with classical
architecture, as opposed
to these ugly buildings,
which the Prince assigns
to modern architecture.
So here is the attempt to use
an architectural form, derived
from classicism quite
freely, to maintain
a certain civility of form
and a certain expression,
which is universally
admired and understood,
instead of the
arbitrary selections
of form under modernism.
Next.
In the Holocaust
Museum in Washington,
the architect says that
he wishes to excavate
memory instead of history.
So he makes the intellectual
leap, or the artistic leap,
by taking forms which
emanate from Auschwitz,
and introducing them into
the vocabulary of forms
that he uses in the Holocause--
bricks, steel, triangular
metal sections.
Next.
In keeping with
Washingtonian urbanism,
the interior of the
building is exotic.
The performance of the
building as it faces the public
is quiet.
Next.
Similarly, on the left is a plan
by a Dutch landscape architect
of, up above, field patterns.
Below is a housing project
based on the field patterns
of the previous agriculture.
And on the right is a
house in Switzerland
by Mario Botta, who says,
"I'm obliged to build
a building in suburbia and
isolate the building, which
I don't like.
I'm going to do it,
but at the same time,
I'm going to deviate its form
so significantly that it's
a different product altogether."
So here is the
argument on the left
that there's enough trace
again for you to impose on it
an argument of consonance.
On the right is an acceptance
of a certain spatial vocabulary,
but then in particular denying
the vocabulary by making it
round.
Next.
Here is a simple example.
In Groningen, in
Holland, a library
is extended by building
it as exactly--
building two new
arms of it parallel
to the existing building.
There's no question but
that they should look like.
Next.
And lastly, a few
ideas from Washington.
Washington's plan made
selecting site for monument
and the maintenance of memory
through monument quite easy.
Next.
Let's jump to the
contemporary problem.
These are two.
On the left is the first attempt
to design the FDR Memorial.
These panels of stone are taller
than the Washington Monument.
The family objects.
Another architect is
brought in to reduce
the height of the panels
down to a smaller level.
Next.
The last outcome was the attempt
to leave architecture alone
and to use a garden as
the appropriate memorial.
Now, this is either because
contemporary architecture
has no way of doing memorials.
Do you know Frank
Geary's proposition
for the Eisenhower Memorial?
Has anybody seen it?
It's under grave
discussion at the moment
as to whether it's
acceptable or not.
It has none of Geary's formal
language of architecture
as embedded in the project.
This is a case where nature
is seen as invariably benign.
If you can't do a man-made
manifestation of something,
you rely on nature
to do it for you.
Next.
This is a late 19th
century attempt
to cover the existing obelisk
with an armature which renders
it more publicly acceptable.
It's probably the
finiteness of a monument.
The obelisk is, after all,
a very elementary geometry,
which needs to be denied
by those who need to give
it more appropriate meaning.
The same thing on the right.
This is Ross Perot's addition
to the Vietnam Memorial.
Maya Lin's memorial
is absently abstract.
It has only vertical
planes with names on it.
In order to render
it more acceptable,
we get the addition of this
example of human soldiers.
No women, of course.
The abstraction allows
almost everybody
to take part in it, whereas once
you express particularities,
you have the problem of what
particularities to choose.
An obelisk is universal.
A decorated obelisk
means that somebody
had to make decisions about what
is the appropriate decoration.
Next.
And two last examples of
a contemporary monument
are expressions of the need to
retain memory about something.
On the left is the Navy
Memorial in Washington.
It's a developer project which
has left a space in front,
a circular space with a single
figure of a soldier that
is the Navy sailor.
It's a male again-- white
male, on top of the world.
But at the same time, you
enter a door to the right,
and you go inside
this interior space,
where you can see a movie about
the wonder of the United States
Navy.
And there's also
a computer which
will show your grandchild
how wonderful you were
when you were a young sailor.
Next.
The Air Force Memorial
tried to do the same thing.
Here is the first project
for the Air Force Memorial.
It sits on a plinth,
which is the updated
version of the world on top of
a symbolic representation, which
is fixed.
Here, you have a
combination of the idea
that the memorial, which is
only fixed and not updatable,
needs to have an updating system
as a part of a binary system--
one perpetual one
updated contemporary.
I think these two are
examples of a kind of move
to democratize or bring
architectural form
into everyday existence.
I don't know how
successful these will be.
Next.
It's the [INAUDIBLE] OK, we've
gone through a whole series
of examples of issues.